hello you're playing the waiting game
this is the show that gets you ready for
launch day by suggesting similar stuff
coming up today it's everyone's favorite
man with cat eyes not that it's hard for
him to be everyone's favorite men with
cat eyes are quite rare yes go out the
long-haired Slayer of all things wicked
is back for another round of sword
swinging action in The Witcher 3 develop
a CD Projekt RED hasn't yet graced us
with a release date making it all the
more important to know what you should
check out in the hinterland between now
and the currently mythical launch day so
grab your armor and get ready to engage
in some surprisingly explicit sex scenes
friend not with me don't worry first up
in this feral bit of frippery is the
excellent Game of Thrones adapted from
an ongoing series of books by george RR
martin known as a song of ice and fire
game of thrones is an obscenely popular
TV show from HBO it follows the masa
nations of several warring families for
control of the continent of Westeros
along with a whole bunch of supernatural
stuff like fire-breathing dragons you
know for kicks while the perspective of
both the books and the TV show bounced
around a lot as opposed to the which are
following one man's determined quest
game of thrones is nonetheless very
totally similar to the witcher series
and is thoroughly engrossing let's go
kill them also given that it's HBO Game
of Thrones is pretty much a lot of
fighting and nookie which is pretty bang
on the money of the first two Witcher
games or anything to go by but if
endlessly detailed descriptions of meals
or TV shows starring Sean Bean aren't
your bag you could always try reading
something a little closer to home see
someone unusually for a video game The
Witcher is actually based off a series
of novels by andresa pawelski whose name
I almost certainly just mispronounced
currently there's a series of short
stories and six novels of Al Gore out of
rivia and his adventures at least three
of which have been faithfully translated
from the original polish Poland is
undoubtedly where these books have the
greatest influence but if you're a witch
a fan already you stand to gain a hell
of a lot from giving them a go
yourself okay so you may run a slight
spoiler risk but getting attached to the
lore surrounding a game before you play
it is the best possible way to get ready
for launch and will undoubtedly deepen
your appreciation of the game world once
you're free to run around in it he could
only follow his heart but Johnny I'm
xenophobic you say I don't want to read
something that was originally written in
Polish well that's quite a narrow view
to take on world literature but just
this once I'm going to humor you not
happy about it mind the first law is a
series of fantasy books written by a man
named Joe Abercrombie presumably nothing
to do with the preppy clothing brand
there are six books in all three
standalone novels and one trilogy the
first of which is called the blade
itself which was met with great critical
acclaim with a strong cast of
interesting characters the blade itself
combined some riveting fantasy action
with more than a pinch of moral
ambiguity much in the same vein as The
Witcher games just over 500 pages it's
maybe not the shortest of reads but if
the idea of warring kingdoms and
itinerant rogues gets you walking funny
then you really can't go wrong almost
every major character in the first law
books has a bloody past and oppressing
goal putting is very much in mind of the
scarred and determined guralt if you're
scared of spoiling plot details about
the witcher 3 by reading the books on
which it's based this is the perfect
substitute hooray for books now if
you've never played The Witcher before
you should really know that it's a bit
on the tricky side you're not allowed to
quaff potions willy nilly mid combat for
instance this isn't Skyrim it's not
Dragon's Dogma either but Dragon's Dogma
is nonetheless a lovely little game to
romp through before strapping a couple
of swords to your back and running
around the wilderness in the witcher 3
released by capcom in 2012 is an open
world fantasy game with a bit of hack
and slash and a whole lot of dungeon
whereas the witcher 3 features just one
player character Dragon's Dogma has the
usual assortment of fantasy archetypes
to choose from as well as a number of
NPCs you can recruit to follow you
around and make combat a little bit
easier all in all Dragon's Dogma will
give you an easier ride gameplay-wise
then the witcher 3 which should ease you
into the greater challenge that lies
ahead
also rather charmingly the game centers
around your character trying to track
down the dragon that stole your heart at
least up would be charming if the dragon
hadn't literally stolen your heart by
tearing it out of your chest still the
course of true love never did run smooth
and for our final recommendation this
week we're staying firmly in the fantasy
realm but breaking out of the medieval
into the modern day and what is probably
my most favorite found footage film of
all time okay so I still can't make up
my mind as to whether the title is
inspired or ridiculous but troll hunter
is a truly brilliant film about a man
who worm hunts trolls in secret for the
new egin government taking a lawn mow
slee confined to children's stories and
the witcher it tells a truly riveting
tale of some film students who follow
the eponymous troll hunter as he tries
to police these mythical beasts and keep
them from interfering with the
unsuspecting people of Norway while
found-footage films have been done to
death the execution saves the film from
mediocrity making troll hunter a pithy
romp with some truly brilliant set
pieces
I don't want to say any more than that
as it's great fun discovering it for
yourself just make sure you give it a
watch I don't even care if you hate
subtitles well they can one you know all
right that's it from me for this week
but as ever if you want to check out any
of the stuff we talked about during this
episode followed the link on screen now
to check out a list on Amazon I'll be
back next week but in the meantime feel
free to make your own recommendations by
leaving a comment or tweeting with the
hashtag GS waiting game bye for now